>> WELCOME BACK.
BOMBSHELL NEW DEVELOPMENT IN THE
WAKE OF MICHAEL COHEN'S HEARING
ON CAPITOL HILL.
REPUBLICANS ASKED IF HE WAS
COACHED BY DEMOCRATS BEFOREHAND.
SOURCES SAY COHEN MET WITH THE
STAFF OF DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
SCHIFF LEADING UP TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY LAST WEEK.
COHEN'S LAWYER SAID IT WAS
APPROPRIATE AND HE WOULD HAVE
DONE THE SAME THING FOR
REPUBLICANS HAD THEY ASKED.
I WILL START WITH YOU.
>> BRIAN IS WRITING THIS AND I
CAN'T READ WHAT IT SAYS.
>> FOR THE PEOPLE AT HOME.
THE REASON I AM GOING TO DANA
AND BRIAN AT FIRST.
THEY WERE INTO THIS BEFORE.
THEY ARE FIRED UP.
>> I AM NOT FIRED UP.
I DON'T REALLY CARE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> YOU THINK IT'S A HUGE DEAL
THAT SCHIFF IS SHIFTY.
>> DANA, SCHIFF IS DOWNPLAYING
THIS.
THAT IT'S NORMAL, IS IT?
>> I WANT TO HEAR HER YELL AT
BRIAN AND YOU YELL BACK.
>> SOMEONE START.
>> LOOK, LANNY DAVIS IS THE
LAWYER.
HE IS A GOOD ONE AND BEEN
THROUGH THIS BEFORE.
THE COMMITTEE SAID YOU LIED TO
US LAST TIME YOU WERE HERE.
WE WANT TO GO THROUGH THIS TO
WALK IT THROUGH.
MAYBE THAT'S INAPPROPRIATE.
THEY OFFERED IT TO THE
REPUBLICANINGS AS WELL AND THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT.
NUMBER 1 THING THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WANTED MICHAEL COHEN SAID
NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
DID THE DEMOCRATS COACH HIM TO
SAY THAT?
THE SECOND HEADLINE WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT DIRECTLY
TELL ME TO LIE.
THOSE ARE THE TWO THINGS THAT
THE PRESIDENT COULD GET IN
TROUBLE FOR.
MICHAEL COHEN SIDED WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THOSE TWO THINGS.
IN THE DEMOCRATS WERE TRYING TO
COACH HIM, THEY DID NOT DO A
GOOD JOB.
>> BRIAN IS RAISING YOUR HAND.
GO.
>> WHAT BOTHERS ME IS THE
DEPOSITION -- DECEPTION.
SCHIFF SAID THEY WERE JUST
WORRIED ABOUT SECURITY.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU TOLD ME SOMETHING I DIDN'T
KNOW.
THAT REPUBLICANS WERE INVOLVED.
THEY WERE SURPRISED.
TURNER WROTE A LETTER SAYING WAS
THIS A REHEARSAL?
NUMBER 2, THE BENGHAZI HEARINGS.
ALL OF THAT CONTROVERSY, THERE
WAS ONE TIME WHEN A DEMOCRAT WAS
NOT INVITEED TO A ONE-ON-ONE
SESSION WITH A KEY WITNESS
BECAUSE THE WHISTLE BLOWER WAS
NOT SECURE ABOUT IT LEAKING OUT
TO THE MEDIA.
CUMMINGS WENT CRAZY.
DO AT THIS TIME SAME WAY.
NO LEGAL REASON TO BRING
REPUBLICANS IN, BUT IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO TRADITIONALLY.
IT CAME OUT.
THEY SAID TRUMP LAWYERS CHANGED
HIS REMARKS.
THEY DIDN'T.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE WRONG.
THEY FOUND HIS ORIGINAL THE
MOSCOW TOWER TALKS STOPPED IN
JANUARY.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> THE COHEN HEARINGS AT THE END
OF THE DAY, DOES IT HELP OR HURT
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
I WOULD ARGUE IS ABSOLUTELY
HELPED HIM.
>> GREG, WHAT DANA SAID.
>> I WAS NOT LISTENING.
>> IF YOU ARE NOT INTERESTED --
I AM KIDDING.
I AM JOKING.
UNLIKE YOUR CRAZY SHOW IN THE
MORNING.
>> YOU ARE SLEEPING UNTIL NOON.
>> ORDER IN THE COURT.
DOES IT HELP ANYONE TO EMBRACE
MICHAEL COHEN?
>> NO!
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT ADAM SCHIFF
BEING SHIFTY, PEOPLE SAY HE IS
LIKE JOE McCARTY AND ON THIS
WITCH HUNT.
HE IS LIKE CHARLIE McCARTHY.
HE IS A DOLL ON STRING AND THE
STRINGS ARE PULLED BY THE MEDIA.
HE IS BEING REWARDED WITH THE
SPOTLIGHT.
HE WOULD MAKES JOHN CARRY LOOK
LIKE A GUMMY WORM.
HE IS IN CONTROL OF THE MEDIA.
AS LONG AS THE MEDIA IS CHASING
THIS, HE WILL CHASE THEM.
>> I GOT TO SAY, I GOT TO
INTRODUCE YOU TO NUNES.
>> I KNOW HIM.
>> WE PLAY RACQUETBALL.
>> PLAYING WITH THE MEDIA, THAT
WAS DEVIN NUNES WHEN HE WAS IN
CHARGE OF HOUSE INTELLIGENCE.
WHEN YOU STOP AND REVIEW THE
IDEA THIS IS A WITNESS WHO LIED
TO THEM AND TO THE CONGRESS, THE
IDEA THEY WOULD SAY WE WANT TO
REVIEW WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT YOU HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF TO PREPARE GOING
OVER CATCH AND KILL STORIES WITH
THE "NATIONAL ENQUIRER."
>> AXELROD PUT OUT A TWEET WITH
THE DOCUMENT REQUEST FROM 81
PEOPLE SAYING THIS PLAYS INTO
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WITCH HUNT?
>> NO, IT PLAYS INTO THE MEDIA
NARRATIVE.
THE CONGRESS HAS A LEGITIMATE
OVERSIGHT.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> YOU WANT CONGRESS TO
ASCERTAIN THE FACTS BEFORE
BRINGING ANY CHARGES OR GOING
AFTER IMPEACHMENT.
THEY ARE DOING THAT.
THAT'S THEIR ROLE.
>> ISN'T IT REDUNDANT AND
MUELLER HAS BEEN DOING THIS